Jack Grapes, Artist, Writer, Author, Instructor:
You don't have to have a story. You don't have
to have an idea. Just connect with that moment
and maybe you'll write crap but you'll write.
Film Courage: Is that why you love writing poetry,
the rhythm of the writing, the rhythm of the word?
Jack Grapes: Well the rhythm is the rhythm of
the voice. I mean that's the rhythm of the the
deep voice speaking to someone else in a very
intimate way and connecting with him you know
I talked about my dog Jesse who she had cancer
and we had to put her down it's in one of my books
I like I like different sizes I like when
I'm doing a book I like to think what size
do I want it to be like lucky finds with all the
cards now most most of my books are going to be
you know the normal size of a book but once
in a while I I'm curious so like I did a book
of haiku oh yeah and I wanted it to be a flip
book so I thought it would be about that thick
and it would be 50 haiku but it ended up I
wrote 300 haiku and I wrote a introduction
that was uh close to 450 pages oh so it's got a
450 page introduction and then it's got 301 haiku
and the introduction is what does it say here
it says in 201 chapters and 601 paragraphs so
the little book I was going to do ended up being
like that and it kind of grew so I kind of like
different things this book is a smaller book
too and it has a I think of it as a circus
the poems are all different and I have a chagall
painting in the front and on the back it's got
a roomy quote with passion prey with passion make
love with passion eat and drink and dance and play
why look like a dead fish in the ocean of god
rumi so I have a poem in here that is about my dog
Jesse this is not an earth-shattering poem it's
just about my dog Jesse who we had to put down
Jesse my dog I was driving back from a
music recital this evening and found myself
cruising down a street I used to frequent
30 years ago but haven't driven down since
so many of the places I used to go to are gone a
favorite Italian restaurant now a fitness center
a bookstore now an antique store a cafe
where I read most of 100 years of solitude
now an ice cream parlor it isn't as if I
was planning to go to any of those places
but it makes me sad to know they're gone
it doesn't really matter I'm 72 years old
a lot is gone it's all gonna go eventually by the
cafe a boy was walking his dog along the sidewalk
one day the boy will be gone along with his dog
my dog is gone Jesse used to lie by my feet as
I sat at the computer trying to write a poem
she's gone now no more jessie after i'd written
the poem i'd take jessie out for her midnight walk
sometimes we'd pass a house and the people
inside might still be up sitting at the table
talking and drinking but mostly the streets were
quiet and she and I would enjoy the night air
the way the leaves rustled when a wind came up
from the ocean maybe a poem would be buried in
someone's front yard and Jesse would dig it up
and bring it to me like a bone she just found
that poem about the man in charge of watering
Jesse dug that one up she just dug it up and
brought it to me what you got there girl she
dropped it on the sidewalk then trotted off
looking for more poems more bones no more bones
now and few poems to be dug up except this one
which is torn at the edges and i've stopped caring
about the line breaks or the metaphors or even the
kind of things a poet is supposed to do when
writing a poem making everything ship shape
no more bones no more ship shape I'm not even
sure you are reading this poem right now maybe
no one is reading it like I said
earlier it doesn't matter you know
I write the poems anyway Jesse will come
back some night take my poems on our walk
and bury them in someone's front yard and
all i'll have to do in my remaining years
is walk my weary bones down the sidewalk and
dig them up dig up those poems that Jesse buried
my good girl talk taking such
good care of me then and now
Jesse won't be with me but i'll thank her give
her a good rub on the back then i'll let her go
so that's about my dog Jesse that's beautiful
so it's not so much rhythm as the voice
you know sometimes there are rhythmic things
you can do and that's part of your technique
so it depends if I'm doing to be read and sung you
know the repetition then I would do that you know
it's also about loss and change you know
you talked about walking down the street and
the this restaurant isn't here anymore and this
bookstore has changed well it's about I'm 70 I
wrote that when I was 72 I'm 78 now so I wrote
that six years ago it's about thinking you know
as I said my dad died when he was 54 and I wasn't
I always thought I would live longer than he did
so you know when I wrote the poem I was 72 and
you know I'm feeling older your bones your body
you don't you know I can't dunk anymore
you know I can't throw a football 70 yards
uh and so you also think of what you can't
do as an artist that you're getting older and
uh things are gonna be gone you're gonna lose
things friends will die and loved ones will
leave and I was just thinking about that and
feeling all that and that jessie was gone but
I thought of how she would bury my poems and
then dig them up which is a metaphor of course
and that eventually i'd pet her and let her go
that at some point the poems don't come anymore
and the muse that brings you the poems
whether it's your dog or the muse or whatever
that will end too and you have to let it go you
have to give him a pet and let it go whether it's
a poem or a lover a loved one friend whatever
what do you mean by the muse won't come anymore
well the muse you know I don't I don't believe
in the muse but I'm just using that cliche that
you know poets sit and write and the muse comes
and gives you the poem I don't believe that I
believe that you the muse is in you but I just use
that cliche as a kind of the idea that you'll be
sitting at your desk and nothing will come
to you anymore you know the muses will say
you know we got to work with this guy in chicago
he's just 20 years old he's just starting out uh
you know take care of yourself jack so I use that
cliche that the the muse won't come anymore you
you you won't have it what an athlete can
lose it a writer can lose it you never know
but can you lose it for a while and get it back
I know the the writer's block but is that really
that the muse won't come anymore well I look
but we're getting into technicalities here
I don't believe in writer's block okay I
can write a sentence hemingway once said
uh when he had write his block he said he
would write this down you've done this before
you can do it again all you have to do is write
one true sentence he didn't mean true factually
he meant a sentence that was authentically
spoken and real and not trying to be a
writer and not trying to gussy it up just
saying the simplest thing you could say
you've done this before you can do it again
all you have to do is write one true line
well I don't have writer's block you
know why because here's what I write
i got up this morning at seven o'clock
I don't feel like writing today I don't have
anything to write about it looks like it's gonna
rain and later I have to go to ralph's to get a
chicken blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
I don't know what I'm going to write about
but I don't care I'm just I'm going to write
well I don't feel like writing I have nothing
to write about I feel like I have writer's block
but of course I never have writer's block I don't
know what it is a big wooden thing inside my head
just write you don't have to have
a story you don't have to have an
idea just connect with that moment and
maybe you'll write crap but you'll write
I don't believe in writer's block I don't believe
in the muse and inspiration and all of that stuff
I believe in the mechanics of art I believe if
you know how to hit a a golf ball and you know
how to hit shoot a basketball and you practice
it a thousand times then even if you're not in
the mood you can pick up the damn ball and shoot
a hoop I can pick up the damn club and hit the
ball maybe I can only hit it 10 feet because
my bones are old and I'm tired but I can do it
I don't have to have I need to be inspired
to play golf today imagine if a professional
athlete said I only play when when I'm inspired
you know there goes that million dollar contract
why do people call themselves blocked writers
i don't know I'm not a their therapist
they're operating under an illusion
they're not very professional yeah if I
get an injury I don't go and play that day
but if I'm not injured I play I don't feel
like it but I play because I got to play
according to the schedule so I can get up and
write i've done it before I can do it again
all I have to do is write one true line I got
up this morning at seven o'clock I don't feel
like writing today as a matter of fact I have
nothing to write about it looks like it's gonna
rain and later I got to go to ralph's to get
a chicken blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
it's not magic do you think people romanticize
being a blocked writer makes them more tragic
makes them maybe get some sympathy maybe but if
they write about it that would be good there you
go see if you're right about it you know I
feel blocked today all right write about it
i just think you know if you can physically
hold the pencil or type at your keyboard you
can write something but what happens is when
you think of your product and your outline
how am I going to get from point a to b in
my outline oh I where am I going to start
and what happens when the door closes and oh god
I have writer's block I don't worry about that.
Do professional writers get writer's block?